[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats de reportage et d'analyse sur
Public Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du
sens à l'actualité grâce à nos experts
de thèmes comme chaque soir et pour
commencer c'est un bilan des 6 premiers
mois d'Elisabeth borne à Matignon que je
vous propose le 16 mai elle est choisie
par le Président de la République de moi
plus tard elle fendit l'armure lors de
son discours de politique générale et
rend hommage à la République
c'est elle qui m'a tendu la main en me
faisant pupille de la nation alors que
j'étais cet enfant dont le père n'était
jamais vraiment revenu des camps
c'est elle qui m'a montré que le travail
peut déjouer les destins tracés et qui
m'a donné un métier
pour devenir la première femme à occuper
le poste depuis Edith Cresson je
voudrais dédier cette nomination à
toutes les petites filles en leur disant
allez au bout de vos rêves et rien ne
doit freiner le combat pour la place des
femmes dans notre société après des
débuts tumultueux marquer notamment par
l'éviction de Damien Abba du
gouvernement Elizabeth borne doit
affronter le scrutin des législatives
élus de justesse dans le Calvados elle
sauve sa tête et se met au travail pour
faire adopter les textes du gouvernement
elle promet une méthode la concertation
nous mènerons pour chaque sujet une
concertation dense nous aborderons
chaque texte dans un esprit de dialogue
de compromis et d'ouverture à son bilan
l'adoption des projets de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat et sur l'assurance
chômage mais privé de majorité absolue à
l'Assemblée Elisabeth borne doit
dégainer à trois reprises le 49-3 pour
faire adopter 100 votes les textes
budgétaires
sur alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement pour la première partie du
projet de loi de finance pour 2023
surnommé madame 49.3 la première
ministre affronte avec succès 4 notions
de censure six mois après son arrivée à
Matignon Elisabeth borne a encore bien
des chantiers devant elle la réforme des
retraites le projet de loi sur
l'immigration ou encore celui sur les
énergies renouvelables
écoutez on commence ce débat dans la
bonne humeur et ben ça fait du bien un
premier tour de table tiens je vais vous
demander aux uns et aux autres peut-être
pas encore le bilan général parce qu'on
va le faire pendant 45 minutes mais une
anecdote a fait un fessaillant Emmanuel
je commence par un une info que j'ai
trouvé dans votre article que je trouve
assez éclairante finalement sur la
personnalité de la première ministre
elle a pas cédé aux Orres de la
République ou Vittel aujourd'hui elle
vit dans un appartement en première
étage sans vue dans le 14e
arrondissement sans aucun charme ni
intérêt particulier voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui effectivement a survécu
assez simplement et qui par son histoire
que je raconte dans cet article en fait
c'est c'est voué au travail corps et âme
et et effectivement est assez peu
sensible on va dire à tout ce qui est
apparent du pouvoir c'est intéressant
déjà de de pointer c'est le fait de ce
trait de caractère est-ce qu'il y a un
faux saillant il s'appelle parlons de la
communication qui est votre principal
domaine de compétence qui ressort pour
vous de ces six premiers mois mais je
trouve que surtout ce qui est ce qui est
saillant c'est qu'à la garder son style
n'a pas elle a pas cherché à être
quelqu'un d'autre à être une grande
oratrice on disait d'elle qu'elle était
techno un peu tristounette un peu un peu
rigide un peu dur et finalement elle est
restée comme elle est restée assez
naturelle et fidèle à ce qu'elle est on
lui on l'a disait techno bah elle est
techno et elle fait ça moi dans les
fessaillants dans les moments saillants
c'est quand elle a fait son discours
aussi de politique générale j'ai trouvé
qu'elle distribuait des petits pics est
assez donné à elle-même de l'assurance
elle distribuait à chacun elle les a
interpellés chacun des chefs de groupe
de l'opposition en distribuant des pics
en disant attention je vous ai à l'oeil
parce que vous avez voté vous avez fait
ça aussi et on sentait que ça la rassuré
elle-même et qu'elle prenait confiance
dans ce style très particulier mais
qu'elle a pas changé finalement Jean
garrigue même question un moment clé
pour vous
dire souvent comme Émilie parce que
parce que ce qui m'a frappé c'est
qu'elle voilà elle est toujours restée
droit dans cette droite dans ses bottes
c'est une référence Alain Juppé mais
dans son dans son style sans concession
démagogique on va dire et aussi son ça
déclaration de politique générale où je
l'avais trouvé j'allais dire meilleur
que ce que on aurait pu redouter et
c'est parce qu'on avait des a priori
négatives directement j'ai trouvé
d'ailleurs qui avait eu beaucoup
d'apriori négatifs ça m'a pas tellement
étonné puisque Edith Cresson on avait
encaissé encore beaucoup plus à l'époque
30 ans plus tard on en est toujours au
même point mais c'est vrai que si on
compare avec les six premiers mois
d'édit de cresson elles sentir quand
même beaucoup mieux alors ça je vous
reposerais la question plus tard parce
que ça serait intéressant de détailler
Mathieu bah elle était intéressante
cette déclaration de poétique générale
parce que Elisabeth borne con caricaturé
en techno et enfin qu'on caricaturé on
décrivait en découle parce que c'était
une techno voilà et c'est révélé
beaucoup plus politique qu'on
l'imaginait effectivement en
interpellant les chefs de groupe
majoritaire pour essayer de dessiner
avec les uns et les autres de les
coincer un peu les taquiner mais surtout
de dessiner des axes de ce qui pouvait
être sa nouvelle façon gouverner c'est à
dire avec Monsieur
Marleix on va pouvoir faire des choses
avec Monsieur Vallot socialiste je vous
ai entendu quand on en a discuté
ensemble et cette façon dire
construisons des majorités
dans les faits pour l'instant on en a
pas vu beaucoup la couleur parce que on
a eu essentiellement des textes
budgétaires on a eu des textes un peu
compliqués cet été mais en tout cas où
qui ont réussi à passer quand même et on
a eu des textes budgétaires qui ont été
adoptés avec le 49-3 mais ça prouve
quand même une habileté qu'on a pu voir
aussi dans la façon qu'elle a eu de
traiter notamment les sénateurs de façon
très différente des députés de dessiner
aussi avec eux peut-être des axes et là
encore des textes sont passés donc voilà
moi c'est plutôt il y a pas un événement
parce qu'il y a pas il y a pas eu un
numéro de claquettes incroyable il y a
pas eu un retournement de situation elle
n'a pas renversé la table mais se
dessine au fil du temps un profil
beaucoup plus politique
j'allais dire profil bas sans en
rajouter sans éclat mais qui peut
peut-être dessiner une façon de
gouverner alors un zoom sur sa côte de
popularité avec le dernier baromètre
Ipsos publié hier à la question quel
jugement portez-vous sur l'action
d'Elisabeth borne le le la réponse
favorable est à 32% défavorable à 59% et
alors si on regarde la tendance c'est
toujours intéressant de regarder les
tendances mais on voit que depuis son
arrivée en mai dernier la courbe de de
son impopularité que voyant rouge elle
progresse très nettement on est parti de
27 on est à 59 je commence avec vous là
dessus Jean garrigue est-ce que c'est
forcément le destin des des locataires
de Matignon on a souvent vu une
popularité qui était corrélée à celle du
président de la République c'est pas
toujours vrai mais est-ce que c'est le
destin des locataires de Matignon de
devenir petit à petit régulièrement un
populaire pas forcément
pour de prendre un exemple qui pourrait
être similaire que c'était celui de
Michel Rocard avec une majorité relative
Michel Rocard est resté à des à des
hauteurs quand même bien plus élevés que
que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui mais je
pense aussi que là le contexte joue un
rôle majeur ce deuxième quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron il a commencé quand
même dans une forme de morosité pour ne
pas dire plus et qui atteint aussi la
première ministre mais dans la mesure où
elle se situe dans une une marge qui est
assez similaire une marge d'impopularité
à celle du chef de l'État je pense que
le couple peut tenir de cette manière si
vous voulez parce que si elle était
vraiment beaucoup plus impopulaire que
lui c'est un moment ça a été ça va être
le cas de Jean-Marc Ayrault avec
François Hollande s'imposait un gros
problème et à contrario si elle était
beaucoup plus populaire que lui voir
Édouard Philippe avec Emmanuel Macron
s'imposerait aussi un problème donc d'un
point de vue assez cynique qui est celui
de la comparaison des cours de
popularité je trouve que finalement ça
peut fonctionner comme ça alors ça veut
pas dire que je lui souhaite de
descendre à 15% de popularité mais il y
a pour l'instant je dirais que ça il y a
une sorte d'équilibre qui s'est créée
est-ce qu'il lui manque finalement un
pour l'opinion une colonne vertébrale ou
un ou un domaine particulier sur lequel
on sent que voilà ça l'enflamme ça lui
donne de envie de se battre mais
finalement elle est un peu sur le même
ton quel que soit les les thèmes ou les
ou les textes dont elle parle ah oui
tout à fait c'est surtout le défaut de
ses qualités comme disait Mathieu c'est
vrai qu'elle a du pragmatisme politique
elle va négocier avec les uns les autres
ça se voit pas beaucoup puisque ça ça se
fait dans les couloirs on va dire donc
c'est pas très flagrant ça et ce qu'on
voit d'elle c'est absolument pas
d'incarnation d'une thématique
particulière et pour par exemple je la
voyais sur BFM l'autre soir sur les
spéciales sur l'écologie le problème
c'est que moi je me demande même si elle
est convaincue parce que c'est vrai
quand on l'entend c'est pas convaincant
elle cherche ses mots alors c'est encore
une fois c'est une écologie très
pragmatique mais qui font les passer par
ce ministère
pas de vision moi je suis d'accord elle
est politique dans les alliances mais
elle est pas politique dans la vision
politique et elle porte pas d'ailleurs
c'est assez difficile de voir ce que
Emmanuel Macron porte réellement et elle
n'en porte pas plus donc ça m'étonne pas
trop aussi cette cote de popularité
parce que tout ce qu'elle fait comme
travail c'est du compromis qui ne se
voit pas et tout ce qui est extérieur on
ne voit pas de vision et sur l'écologie
je pense que c'est un problème elle a
voulu sans saisir c'était un peu la
promesse au départ planification
écologique elle y arrive pas elle fait
de la région PACA la première région
pilote sur sa planification écologique
Macron reprend la main en répondant aux
questions des internautes donc on
l'entend pas du tout elle n'est pas du
tout audible sur cette thématique et je
pense que ça pose un problème à ce
gouvernement il y a aucune incarnation
de l'écologie ni d'elle ni d'Emmanuel
Macron parce que répondant aux
intermènes je pense que ça suffit pas et
ni de Christophe Béchu dont on entend
pas la voix le ministre de la transition
aussi de l'Élysée enfin du président de
la République
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile c'est
pas facile parce que c'est un dossier
qui est majeur elle était la première
ligne chargé d'incarner dossier c'était
une thématique qu'elle connaît quand
même très bien pour avoir été au cabinet
de Ségolène Royal quand c'est Gwen Royal
était ministre de la transition
écologique elle a été elle-même ministre
de l'écologie et donc il y a pas de
défaut de légitimité mais il y a un
défaut d'incarnation en gros si on
résume je trouve Élisabeth band depuis 6
mois on peut le faire les politiques ça
se résume à 3 questions est-ce qu'elle a
réussi à faire est-ce qu'elle a réussi à
gouverner oui voilà c'était pas gagné
d'avance tout le monde suspectait
tellement qu'elle puisse tomber d'un
côté ou de l'autre voilà mais elle a
réussi à gouverner la France parce que
les lois globalement qu'elle a pour but
qu'elle a voulu porter ont été votés
est-ce qu'elle a réussi à dire à se
faire comprendre et là je rejoins tout à
fait Émilie non pour le coup il y a pas
de casse il y a pas de vision est-ce que
c'est uniquement de sa faute non parce
qu'elle est quand même dans un second
quinquennat qui est un peu flottant où
on a porté la transition écologique au
sommet mais il faut maintenant que ça se
traduise dans les actes et puis voilà on
va débloquer réformer la France tous les
immeubles soit du question sur la santé
il y a pas encore de vision on peut pas
résumer d'un slogan l'action
gouvernementale donc ça elle n'a pas
réussi et enfin troisième question
est-ce qu'elle a réussi à se faire
apprécier et là on n'y est pas encore
d'abord tous les politiques ne sont pas
appréciés dans le rôle à Matignon
certains y arrives c'est vrai que j'en
ai rappelé Michel Rocard Édouard
Philippe en fin à la fin mais Édouard
Philippe a connu aussi un mouvement un
peu cascade mais voilà donc on en est
pas là elle a pas encore les moyens de
se faire apprécier et encore moins aimer
mais voilà ça ça viendra peut-être avec
le Emmanuel
tiens ça code de popularité ou le regard
des autres se faire aimer se faire
apprécier bien sûr elle est obligée elle
est premier ministre forcément elle
regarde après c'est un problème depuis
le début avec son équipe depuis le début
se dit comment va-t-on faire pour la
rendre humaine
chaleureuse c'est quelqu'un qui a quand
même été pendant cinq ans sur le premier
gouvernement Macron et personne ne la
connaissait c'est-à-dire que même en
tant que ministre du Travail c'est enfin
quelqu'un qui n'apparaissait pas en fait
c'est elle règle les dossiers les après
les autres c'est vrai que c'est une
techno et donc elle a pas elle voilà
c'est pas elle a pas vu du panache de de
même de la prise de parole on voit bien
que pour elle c'est toujours compliqué
il y a un truc un peu risqué elle a
choisissait mot elle est pas
complètement à l'aise quand tu es pas
dans des émissions type quotidien un peu
comme ça on sent qu'elle est pas du tout
à l'aise elle est pas débridée enfin
voilà elle fait attention elle est très
très claque murée c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours vécu comme ça d'une manière
très très
contrôlé en fait elle contrôle tout elle
protège elle se protège parce qu'elle a
donc une histoire très particulière et
qui fait que c'est quelqu'un qui sait
toujours protégé depuis toute petite et
là et on lui demande d'incarner cette
fonction de sortir de son de son de son
carcan en fait techno et c'est vrai
qu'elle a du mal au moment de son petit
de discours général c'est intéressant
parce que là elle a fondu l'armure un
peu vous avez montré cette phrase sur
son père c'était quelque chose de
personnel jusqu'au dernier moment elle
elle arriverait à le dire elle a fini
par le dire la veille elle avait même
pas réussi à prononcer cette phrase et
là on sent qu'en fait tous ces de
nouveaux recontrôler refermés parce
qu'elle est dans une situation politique
évidemment très difficile
donc le discours de politique générale
d'Elizabeth borne à l'Assemblée
nationale effectivement elle fait
référence à son histoire par personne
elle rend hommage à la République en
écoute
Premier ministre de la France je le dois
à la République
c'est elle
c'est elle qui m'a tendu la main en me
faisant pupille de la nation alors que
j'étais cet enfant dont le père n'était
jamais vraiment revenu des camps
c'est elle qui m'a montré que le travail
peut déjouer les destins tracés et qui
m'a donné un métier voilà son père qui
effectivement avait été déporté dans
dans les camps nazis cette phrase on l'a
cherché évidemment quand elle fait le
son discours de politique générale ici
devant le Sénat elle l'a pas reponcé
donc ça ça a rejoint un peu ce que vous
disiez sur la difficulté de de faire
référence à cette histoire familiale
elle naît le 18 avril 1961 et vous
décrivez dans enfin vous raconte dans
l'appartement familial une ambiance qui
est très lourde en fait donc son père
qui est revenu décan
c'est jamais remis de de feed c'est et
de cette période et donc c'est quelqu'un
qui ne dormait pas la nuit donc elle
petite fille avec sa grande sœur
entendait le père marchait toute la nuit
c'est quelqu'un qui était dépressif et
voilà les les fenêtres il y avait des
barreaux fenêtres parce qu'on avait peur
de ce qui pouvait se passer enfin c'est
évidemment une ambiance très lourde qui
d'ailleurs a été donc c'est très mal
terminé puisque son papa c'est suicidé
quand elle avait 11 ans et à partir de
là clairement je suis interrogé des
membres aussi de sa famille autour
d'elle et pasquelle c'est elle à 11 ans
elle s'est dit bah voilà mon mon père se
suicide sa mère à ce moment-là part elle
se retrouve toute seule et elle se dit
bon bah la seule solution c'est de se
bosser et de se réfugier de se refermer
les maths les maths et le travail
dit-elle
voilà ce qui a été confirmé par sa
grande sœur enfin et donc c'est
quelqu'un qui à ce moment-là devenu un
espèce de bulldozer et qui a traversé la
vie
par le travail et en finance son
histoire vraiment la Fiance d'ailleurs
en essayant de l'oublier elle est partie
de chez elle à 15-16 ans voir il y a
trois photos que vous nous avez proposé
qui sont dans votre article vraiment à
trois âges différents on va on va voir
ces photos d'Elizabeth borne la première
je suis pas très très doué mais elle
doit pas être très loin de l'âge
à la mort de son papa quoi
exactement mais grosso modo elle doit
devoir tourne 10 11 ans la deuxième
photo elle est appelée technique donc
une vingtaine sur une promo depuis 10
ans c'était une vingtaine sur une promo
de 300 mais là aussi les personnes que
j'ai interviewé qui l'ont côtoyé à
l'époque raconte quelqu'un de
d'extrêmement mystérieux presque
dissocié par rapport à ses émotions très
secrètes elle ne parlait pas son
histoire même avec la personne qui
partageait sa salle de bain la jeune
fille qui est même été juive avec elle
aurait pu éventuellement partager elle
ne parlait pas de son passé et pendant
très longtemps elle n'a quasiment jamais
parlé de son passé autour d'elle elle a
travaillé elle a commencé ensuite en
étant effectivement une techno dans les
dans les ministères en bossant
manifestement beaucoup et très bien ces
dossiers à fond et en étant toujours
dans cette espèce de de de
de volonté de ne pas de ne pas
on va dire s'apitoyer retourner sur son
passé et s'apitoyer ni sur les autres ni
sur elle-même et ni sur les autres parce
qu'il y a des considérée comme quelqu'un
de dur ceux qui travaillent avec elle on
y reviendra là-dessus je voudrais je
voudrais Jean garrigue on a commencé à
évoquer évidemment le parallèle entre
Isabelle et de cresson parce que
malheureusement ce n'est que la deuxième
femme nommée à Matignon 30 ans 30 ans
après discrétion est-ce que vous vous
faites un parallèle entre les deux
expériences qui est en quoi il y a des
similitudes pour vous ou peut-être pas
d'ailleurs pas tant que ça à vous
écouter je ferai plutôt un parallèle
avec quelqu'un comme Simone Veil aussi
qui a vécu différent mais qu'on peut qui
peut s'apparenter et avec la difficulté
à dire aussi le traumatisme du génocide
de la Shoah et des camps je veux dire
qu'il y a quelque chose là et et une
manière de se renforcer justement par
par le travail et par l'action politique
dans justement
franchissez il n'y a pas de place
justement pour une autre incarnation que
celle du président de la République
surtout quand vous êtes un président
jupiteria comme quand même Emmanuel
Macron qui est très attaché à cette à
cette idée là qui a qui a ce modèle
gaullien d'antisé parfois très écarté
mais enfin bref ce modèle là si vous
voulez c'est très compliqué et je pense
que précisément le choix de quelqu'un
comme Elisabeth borne il correspond
aussi à cette à cet équilibre
institutionnel nouveau elle est un mot
de Mathieu et ensuite Émilie et une
grosse différence avec éducation c'est
Edith Cresson c'est un choix politique
comme le dit Jean un joker que sort
François Mitterrand pour voilà en fin de
dans son deuxième septennat c'est pas
une personnalité politique qui pèse au
sein du Parti socialiste à l'époque
c'est pas un éléphant du Parti
socialiste mais au contraire c'est un
joker mais elle a un lien avec le
président ce que n'a pas Isabelle borne
et Isabelle borne n'est pas un choix
politique c'est plutôt un choix par
défaut puisqu'on se souvient qu'au
moment de sa nomination elle a fait
partie des profils qui étaient déjà
rentables mais il en a cherché d'autres
Emmanuel Macron et puis c'est le premier
nom qui était sorti et ensuite il s'est
passé
la différence majeure c'est que Edith
Cresson subit dès son installation à
Matignon un procès en incompétence et
avec un vrai un vrai un procès sur son
style parce que elle a un style qui
détonne à l'Assemblée et dans les
relations et dans ses discours et puis
en gros des attaques machistes que je
sache je n'ai je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'il y avait de borne subissent un
procès en incompétence au contraire les
gens disent qu'elle maîtrise ses
dossiers et
un peu mais c'est facile
qui n'avait rien à faire là on a dit
d'Élisabeth Band qui n'était pas
politique et c'est très techno aux
personnes a dit elle ne connaît rien là
ces dossiers et puis sur le machisme
quand même je pense qu'on est beaucoup
plus près on a l'impression et d'autant
plus avec une première ministre qui est
pas trop politique qui a son âge qui est
dans un style un peu techno on remet pas
du tout en question ses compétences on a
l'impression que la France a évolué
là-dessus et qu'on peut avoir une
première ministre alors demandez une
première présidente de la République
c'est peut-être encore un peu trop
demandé mais on s'en approche on a
l'impression bon on espère pas que ça
soit de les système qui remporte la mise
mais en tout cas on a l'impression que
les ça évolue de ce côté là et même je
dirais en termes de figure de
personnalités politiques au féminin je
trouve que ça bouge aussi on n'a pas
besoin moi ça m'a gêné en fait pour tout
vous dire cette vous le dites vous
arrêtez pas de dire en fait elle aime
pas parler de son passé et là c'était le
passage obligé comme tout le monde il
faut faire son petit passage personnel
pour toucher parce qu'en plus on sait
qu'elle est froide et il faut être un
petit peu proche des gens moi j'ai
trouvé que voilà est-ce qu'on a vraiment
besoin de ça elle est très techno ou
quoi mais en tout cas
on voit de plus en plus des styles
Mathilde pano Sandrine Rousseau on a eu
Ségolène Royal on a quand même des
styles de femmes Marine Le Pen des
personnalités politiques au féminin
qu'on remet pas en question et qui
découvre des nouveaux styles par rapport
à des hommes c'est vrai que par contre
ce qu'il y a c'est que moi je trouve
qu'elle rentre dans moi je dirais même
plus que collaborateur c'est dire cab
pour moi et dire cab un petit peu plus
d'Emmanuel Macron en fonctionnant sur
les alliances les compromis que dans les
entreprises au sein de au sein des Comex
des comités exécutifs je trouve que ça
rentre vraiment dans le dans le
mécanisme de Emmanuel Macron d'être très
entrepreneurial d'être très dans
l'entreprise sans trop de vision on
regarde pas trop trop loin mais on gère
les équipes et on gère les alliances au
quotidien ou parcours on avance vite un
mot quand même sur le le machisme
féminisme le machisme elle l'a subi vous
le racontez quand elle sort de
Polytechnique les premiers postes
rendez-vous d'embauche totalement
surréalisme mais le féminisme je
voudrais bien que vous nous racontiez ça
quand elle arrive à Matignon elle doit
un peu batailler pour imposer madame la
Première ministre c'est ça oui c'est pas
si évident c'est-à-dire que elle elle a
voulu d'office mettre madame la Première
ministre et on lui a dit bah ouais mais
enfin tout a été imprimé avec le Premier
ministre et ça va coûter cher quand même
et donc elle elle a beaucoup à la
bataillé en disant au moins ça aurait
été fait une fois il y aura des traces
ce sera et ce sera pérenne et d'autres
qui suivront n'auront plus à batailler
pour ça et c'est vrai que c'est une
c'est une une volonté qui était assez
forte de sa part alors que c'est
quelqu'un qui par ailleurs n'a jamais
porté cette cause de manière très
explicite auparavant c'est pas quelqu'un
qui qui se bat comme le dit d'ailleurs
une de ses copines de sa génération on a
une génération où on s'est battu mais en
silence par les postes qu'on a occupé
mais pas tellement par le discours
à faire virer entre guillemets Damien
Abba de une fois qu'il a été accusé
alors que c'était une de ses promesses
reconnues coupable ça prouve aussi que
ce côté-là est un peu reconnu il a pas
été reconnu enfin il n'a pas été
il y a eu une enquête et elle avait dit
si la justice avance de son côté là s'il
y a des faits nouveau côté justice ça a
pas été très vite un dernier mot sur ce
thème là que du temps d'édits de
création le Premier ministre oui donc on
peut petit à petit on évolue alors elle
trouve évidemment quand elle arrive à
Matignon une situation politique et
sociale difficile d'ailleurs c'est ce
que lui avait rappelé le président du
Sénat dans un message qui lui avait
envoyé et il nous racontait ça bah
c'était un autre micro au printemps
dernier
envoyer un message ce matin pour lui
souhaiter
chance et courage parce que nous allons
devoir
en avoir besoin tous face à une France
qui est inquiète et à une situation qui
est inquiétante situation inquiétante
les finances publiques vous le savez
elles sont particulièrement inquiétantes
dans notre pays inquiétude aussi des
Français qui inquiets pour le pouvoir
d'achat nous vous avons vu lors de
l'élection toutes ces fractures
territoriales notamment entre une France
plutôt rurale et une France
métropolitaine
inquiétude c'était le mot clé de cette
phrase de de Gérard Larcher alors
justement avec Tam traduis qui doit être
juste derrière le rideau bonsoir Tam et
bienvenue à vous vous allez nous
expliquer ce que sont les relations de
la première ministre avec le Sénat bah
écoutez c'est le grand réchauffement on
est passé du froid polaire sous le
précédent quinquennat des températures
plus clémentes sous ce quinquennat assis
tout a commencé d'ailleurs par une
opération séduction ou la première
ministre ami toutes les chances de son
côté on va revenir encore une fois au
mois de juillet pour son discours de
politique générale mais cette fois-ci au
Sénat Elisabeth bande conque une
véritable déclaration d'amour au
sénateurs extrait choisie je n'imagine
pas la République sans le Sénat
le Sénat pourra pleinement agir comme
force de co-construction au service des
territoires et des Français
[Applaudissements]
nous devons nous inspirer de
l'expérience et des pratiques du Sénat
voilà il y en a eu quelques-unes comme
ça j'en ai sélectionné trois donc
j'étais plus la coupe est pleine voilà
qui a touché au coeur les sénateurs qui
ont applaudi vous l'avez vu plusieurs
fois la nouvelle Première ministre qui
ont été très sensibles à ces belles
paroles peut-être aussi un petit peu
étonnée mais qui bien sûr attendez des
actes est-ce qu'il y en a eu des actes
et bien écoutez ça a commencé par des
textos par des coups de fil comme au
début d'une relation amoureuse le
gouvernement a trouvé nos numéros de
téléphone disait les sénateurs de la
majorité de droite donc dès l'été
dernier au moment où il fallait faire
passer les premiers textes c'est à dire
le texte sanitaire ou encore le paquet
pouvoir d'achat et puis même pendant les
vacances ils ont continué à s'appeler
avec courtoisie et même un peu plus que
ça et puis Elisabeth borne a consulté
elle a notamment reçu les présidents de
groupe et elle a su faire manifestement
prenez Hervé Marseille le président du
groupe Union centriste qui appartient à
lui aussi à la majorité lui qui estimait
que le Parlement avait été martyrisé
ignorer maltraité pendant le premier
quinquennat aujourd'hui et bien il est
reçu régulièrement à Matignon il a
confié on m'avait des pains Elisabeth
borne comme froid des techno écoutez moi
je la trouve plutôt drôle et sympa et
même même les proches de Bruno
Retailleau le patron des sénateurs LR
pourtant et pour cause dans une
opposition plus frontale au gouvernement
Lavoux écoutez on nous cajole comprendre
non seulement on nous parle mais on nous
fait passer quelques amendements
les vrais elles sont là exactement force
de constater que plusieurs textes
pénal le gouvernement d'accord c'est
derniers temps il y a eu les textes de
cet été mais aussi l'assurance chômage
le projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables et pourtant du côté de ce
texte là c'était vraiment pas super bien
parti il y a aussi eu la locmin la loi
d'orientation et de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur qui a été voté
au Sénat et par la droite et par la
gauche bref alors qu'Elizabeth borde
multiplie les 49.3 à l'Assemblée et bien
au Sénat ça négocie et ça avance plutôt
alors bien sûr un pas question de se
mettre d'accord non plus surtout
notamment sur les projets de loi de
finances ou encore de financement de la
sécurité sociale ça voudrait dire
appartenir à la majorité il faut pas non
plus trop pousser mais on sait déjà que
sur les deux gros textes de début 2023
le gouvernement compte sur le Sénat sur
les retraites alors que la majorité
sénatoriale est hyper favorable à un
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite elle a d'ailleurs voté dans le
budget de la Sécu mais aussi sur le
sujet de l'immigration alors que le
gouvernement a repris les propositions
du président les républicains de la
commission des lois François Noël buffet
sur les pour simplifier accélérer les
traitements des recours je précise
toutefois que François Noel buffet c'est
l'aile modérée DLR au Sénat et quand je
lui ai demandé s'il était d'accord avec
le gouvernement il m'a tout simplement
répondu mais c'est eux qui sont d'accord
avec moi merci pour tous ces détails
évidemment à l'Assemblée c'est beaucoup
plus difficile et ils appellenti
qu'est-ce que vous diriez de son bilan
parlementaire plutôt à l'Assemblée ils
sont bien de faire celui du Sénat mais
pour l'instant il y a beaucoup de 49,3
évidemment donc forcément
elle a réussi des compromis mais elle a
utilisé aussi le 49-3 ça va être plus
compliqué pour la suite elle a réussi
quand même à faire passer les projets de
loi pouvoir d'achat énergie renouvelable
donc il y a quand même avec l'aide
justement des sénateurs la droite quoi
quelque part cette alliance qu'elle a
pas réussi à l'assembler elle l'a réussi
forcément au Sénat moi je pense que ça
va être plus compliqué pour la suite
parce que on arrive en effet comme ça a
été dit sur le projet de loi immigration
ça va être compliqué parce que Emmanuel
Macron veut jouer du en même temps on
dans une minute ça va être très
compliqué de savoir comment donner des
gages à la fois à la droite voire un
petit peu plus loin et puis à la gauche
ça va être quand même un grand écart
très difficile je pense aussi que sur
les retraites ça va pas être simple et
en plus d'autant plus que c'est un sujet
que les Français n'en veulent pas
personnellement veut finalement alors
c'est une bonne négociatrice mais
globalement ce que je trouve c'est que
jusqu'à maintenant elle a résister par
cette façon ce style dont on parlait à
l'instant et ben elle résiste elle
résiste au coup le fait qu'elle soit pas
trop politique elle peut elle peut
rester à mon avis assez stable et elle
représente une espèce de stabilité dans
ce monde qui va très vite et dans ce
monde qui est inquiétant et ça je pense
que c'est un atout Mathieu effectivement
on peut dire que elle est pas encore
sortie de l'auberge les amis vous allez
dire que les journalistes on est
toujours pareil comment ça va pas on le
dit quand ça va mieux on dit que ça va
pas aller mais voilà on peut se demander
en gros si Elisabeth borne n'a pas mangé
son pain blanc la question je sais pas
décaler au moment où tout le monde
recule s'accorde à dire qu'elle a fini
plutôt par trouver sa place dans des
circonstances qui étaient compliquées et
pourtant tous les mois qui viennent on
vient d'en parler les mois qui viennent
et qui s'annoncent vont être
particulièrement difficiles pour la
première ministre qui va devoir
affronter une situation économique et
sociale explosive des réformes
difficiles on vient de le dire dans un
paysage politique qui reste très
accidenté alors focus pour commencer sur
cette situation économique et sociale
explosive taux de chômage c'est
stabilisé au troisième trimestre ça
baisse plus et ça même augmente dans
certaines catégories notamment chez les
jeunes les milliards qui ont été mis sur
la table par l'État n'ont pas épargné
des fins de mois difficiles aux Français
alors même que les amortisseurs vont
disparaître faut le dire quand même à la
fin de l'année ce sera la fin des 10
derniers centimes de la ristourne à la
pompe qui ont disparaître et puis au
début de l'année prochaine arriveront
dans les boîtes aux lettres les
premières factures de gaz et
d'électricité qui seront majorées de 15%
de quoi déclencher une colère avoir une
explosion sociale mais c'est la grande
question qui agite au sommet de l'État
où on redoute un mouvement de colère
sociale façon gilet jaune en 2018
d'autant que les atermoiements de la
majorité présidentielle sur la question
du des richesses n'arrange pas l'affaire
est-ce que alors il y a pas de pas de
conférence salariale pas de texte sur
l'expert profit pas de texte sur les
super dividendes peut-être la mise en
place du fameux dividende salarié mais
tout ça prendra du temps bref on voit
bien que la situation économique sociale
elle est très très compliquée elle va
être encore plus est-ce que ça peut
menacer le le l'agenda des réformes mais
c'est le second danger pour les bornes
car les réformes à venir on vient de
dire sont pas très pas très facile à
celles des retraites par exemple donc on
est c'est encore la phase de
concertation mais personne ne doute de
l'issue on sait que de toute façon
faudra travailler plus longtemps que ce
soit par le report de l'âge légal ou que
ce soit par le biais de de du nombre de
trimestres cotisés c'est peut-être
nécessaire mais comme la débili ce n'est
pas très populaire et puis que dire des
autres réformes clivantes qui vont
arriver il y a celles sur l'immigration
que porte le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin et à celle sur
l'autonomie des établissements scolaires
l'autonomie de l'école qui était
demandée par par Emmanuel Macron qui
vient de porter par paper Ndiaye ou
encore celle qui naîtra de de l'obscure
Conseil national de la réforme euro
fondation sur le système de santé il va
falloir lui déployer pour elle des
trésors de diplomatie pour trouver à
chaque fois une majorité qui serait une
majorité de circonstances différentes du
précédent texte à chaque fois et vous le
disiez paysage politique accidenté ça
c'est pas vraiment à ranger non parce
que bah la situation elle est délicate
depuis juin dernier alors on pourrait se
dire que elisabeth a fait le plus dur
d'une certaine manière on parvenant à
mener tant bien que mal sa barque
gouvernementale dans cette Assemblée
nationale très tentueuse mais elle a
passé les obstacles budgétaires les plus
russe on a dit à plus de 49-3 là elle
n'y aura plus le droit qu'une fois dans
le reste de la session puisqu'on
rappelle ainsi c'est les règles
institutionnelles et or les oppositions
restent en embuscade chacune dans leur
genre mais elles attendent parfois le
premier lequel trébuche sur sur chaque
texte les ténors de la majorité eux sont
dans les starting blocks déjà pour 2027
que ce soit Bruno Le Maire Gérald
Darmanin Édouard Philippe qu'on entend
moins en ce moment mais enfin tout le
monde se surveille et puis le Président
il garde le doigt sur le bouton rouge de
la dissolution évidemment ce qui
signifierait la fin de partie pour
Elizabeth borne Elizabeth borne on a
surpris son monde depuis 6 mois elle va
devoir confirmer que que la techno qu'on
écrivait c'est bien transformé en animal
politique et voilà peut-être que avec le
temps ça viendra pour l'instant ce qu'on
a vu pleine plutôt dans ce sens Jean
garrigue on a bien compris que le 49-3
elle pourra pas l'utiliser ad vitam
est-ce qu'elle peut construire des
majorités texte par texte d'après vous
l'avez fait justement Michel Rocard on
parlait de majorité stéréo parce que
tantôt il allait un petit peu à droite
tantôt il trouvait des majorités avec
une partie de la gauche c'est évidemment
beaucoup plus compliqué et vous avez
montré tout à l'heure un des hommes clés
me semble-t-il de la réussite ou de
l'échec de d'Elizabeth borne pour
revenir à l'équilibre parlementaire
c'est Gérard Larcher et c'est cette
majorité LR au Sénat et la manière dont
cette majorité peut se conjuguer avec le
groupe LR de la de l'Assemblée nationale
qui lui est totalement fracturé fracturé
par ce qui va se passer c'est-à-dire
l'élection d'un président DLR et par au
fond les deux courants qui s'y qui s'y
coagulent donc là je pense que la la
balle elle est beaucoup dans le camp
justement des des républicains c'est pas
très original de de le dire mais on est
dans un horizon là qui est complètement
incertain du côté des républicains mais
on sait qu'il y a des possibilités
regarder la plupart des textes qui ont
été évoqués là c'est plutôt avec les LR
qui qu'on peut trouver on va voir ce que
ça donne sur les énergies renouvelables
bien sûr c'est aussi ce malin d'avoir
commencé à chaque fois passer en
première lecture au Sénat parce que le
Sénat est quand même un essence
d'élaboration de la loi plus calme moins
clivante et moins clivée qu'à l'assemblé
et donc il y a ce travail de fabrication
de la loi qui s'y fait avec plutôt
chacun à des arrière-pensées politiques
mais ils sont plutôt les sénateurs
portés vers l'intérêt général et là en
passant par le Sénat sur la Love Me la
loi de de programmation du ministre à
l'intérieur sur la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables le gouvernement Élisabeth
burn font le pari que le bon sens va
l'emporter si les parties sont cohérents
ne pourront pas se distinguer de leurs
homologues sénatoriaux alors c'est un
sacré pari parce que à l'Assemblée c'est
très différent mais en tout cas ils
disent la droite ne pourra pas refuser
la réforme des retraites s'ils veulent
être cohérent elle ne pourra pas refuser
la réforme de l'immigration enfin notre
projet loi sur l'immigration s'ils sont
cohérents la gauche et en tout cas les
écologistes ne pourront pas refuser la
loi sur les énergies renouvelables s'ils
sont cohérents on sait très bien que
beaucoup pourront dire non mais ça ne va
pas assez loin donc on s'abstient on va
mais en tout cas c'est le pari que fait
le gouvernement effectivement c'est
habile et email si c'est aussi une façon
de jouer l'opinion c'est-à-dire parce
qu'il y a un tel contraste entre le
travail du Sénat et l'ambiance et le
travail à l'assemblée que bon voilà ça
fait porter finalement sur les
oppositions à l'Assemblée l'échec des
des réformes il y a peut-être ce calcul
aussi je pense qu'il y a ce calcul mais
il y a aussi moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'elle continue quand
même dans la discussion malgré malgré le
49.3 et je pense que globalement c'est
ce que demander les Français
c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait des discussions
alors c'est vrai que c'est bizarre parce
que un projet de loi voté avec des uns
un projet de loi voté avec les autres ça
fait des alliances bizarres ça fait
comme on le disait pas tellement une
vision stratégique très claire ça
dessine quelque chose qui est de l'ordre
de jeu de l'opportunisme
législatif je sais pas comment on
appelle ça une forme de maturité
politique maintenant une forme de
pragmatisme politique qui est plus on
vote qui est possible de voter moi
maintenant ce que je pense et qui vous
en avez parlé c'est plus explosif sur un
effet la crise énergétique la crise dans
les entreprises notamment parce qu'il y
a aussi la fin du quoiqu'il en coûte
même si ça continue un petit peu avec le
fond Ukraine qui a permis aux
entreprises les plus touchées d'être
remboursés sur leur frais factures
d'énergie et tout je pense qu'on arrive
en effet aux dures en janvier 2023 et
tout ce qui va suivre on entend on sent
qu'il y a des défaillances d'entreprise
qui commence à arriver et je pense que
ces mouvements sociaux qui sont là qui
reviennent qui repartent ou quoi sont
toujours un peu là quelque part il y a
une colère et un tapis de colère qui
continue et c'est pas évident que ça
réexplose pas à un moment ou un autre ou
le gouvernement trouve pas la réponse
absolue la réponse absolue jusqu'à
maintenant c'est l'état providence qui
donne à tout le monde évidemment et avec
une équation très très compliquée pour
certaines entreprises celles qui
justement sont en difficulté et à qui on
demande d'augmenter les salaires elles
ne peuvent pas le faire pour celles qui
sont en difficulté Jean gagne oui moi je
suis évidemment bien sûr d'accord avec
cette épée de Damoclès de l'explosion
sociale qui peut servir les intérêts on
va dire des extrêmes et donc qui ont
intérêt à l'encourager mais en même
temps moi j'ai l'impression en même
temps j'ai l'impression c'est pas une
phrase interdite vous savez c'est ce
qu'on montrait les Français avec cette
élection présidentielle et ses élections
législatives un peu contradictoires
c'est que ils ont besoin justement de
voir comment on peut essayer de trouver
des convergences comment on peut essayer
de trouver de la on parlait de
coproduction et non moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est on parle de
pragmatisme là on parle de d'un esprit
positif si vous voulez et là il y a
cette recherche là c'est vrai que
quelqu'un comme elle elle est elle a le
profil pour incarner ça c'est à dire que
penser qu'elle travaille qu'elle est
négociatrice qu'elle est qu'elle est
fidèle au président qui aura pas de coup
tordus il y a quelque chose là qui est
intéressant et si moi je le répète la
réaction le discours le propos de
quelqu'un comme Gérard Larcher par
rapport à cette perspective là elle est
intéressante parce que j'ai remarché
c'est quelqu'un qui est quand même
influent au sein de la famille des
républicains le l'un des candidats la
présidente des républicains c'est Bruno
Retailleau qui vient du Sénat il y a des
éléments comme ça et il faut pas oublier
j'en rajoute un dernier c'est que il va
y avoir le Congrès aussi du Parti
socialiste et que des choses vont
peut-être se jouer peut-être même des
changements de stratégie il nous reste
moins de 5 minutes je reprends la même
seconde parce que je voudrais qu'on
parle de des négociations et notamment
de la réforme des retraites je vous
propose une première réaction celle du
secrétaire général de Force Ouvrière
c'est dans les premiers temps de de
l'arrivée d'Elizabeth borne à Matignon
voici comment il verriez qui évidemment
la côtoyer quand elle était patente de
la SNCF voilà comment il verriez réagit
c'est une personnalité
compétente qualifiée polytechnicienne
ingénieur déposées chaussées dur en
affaires je l'ai dit à plusieurs
reprises il faudra que nous soyons
nous-même à la hauteur
et puis je vous propose tout de suite
d'écouter la première ministre Elisabeth
borne sur la réforme des retraites elle
confirme qu'elle aura bien lieu donc oui
je vous le confirme il y aura une
réforme des retraites et oui cette
réforme entrera en vigueur à l'été 2023
et depuis des semaines des discussions
ont lieu avec les partenaires sociaux
avec tous les partenaires sociaux pour
préparer cette réforme oui Olivier du
soft dialogue travail
approfondi les différents points
pour construire une réforme qui assure
la pérennité de notre système de
retraite pour construire une réforme
juste qui tienne compte de la diversité
des vies professionnelles
Emmanuel anison a dit tout à l'heure
qu'elle s'était dans son histoire
personnelle finalement construit une
carapace ça peut servir en politique à
une carapace est-ce qu'elle aime la
castagne Elisabeth borne
Elizabeth c'est un petit soldat loyal et
c'est quelqu'un qui va au front et elle
a toujours fait et notamment quand elle
est mise et transports elle a su
négocier aussi donc c'est quelqu'un qui
va au front qui est pragmatique et qui
sait négocié donc avec et qui sera le
loyal c'est à dire que si on lui demande
d'y aller elle ira avec tout ça elle a
quand même quelques armes pour pour la
montrer depuis quelques mois quand même
pour avancer reste que cette rigidité
c'est quand même un problème qui peut
s'avérer
très concret si on a à faire par exemple
à des grandes manifestations de russe
Ken là évidemment j'ai jamais connu dans
sa carrière
avec Alain Juppé
de la réforme de l'assurance chômage où
on leur a dit si vous n'êtes pas si vous
avez pas de capable de faire trois ou
quatre milliards d'économies on reprend
la main et c'est ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est vrai qu'elle a continué malgré
tout je pense que sur les retraites
c'est autre chose parce que ça concerne
beaucoup plus de Français globalement
donc et globalement c'est pas une
réforme que les Français veulent donc
c'est quand même et puis juste il y a
aussi un truc c'est que la réforme des
retraites c'est aussi pour cocher
réforme des retraites parce qu'elle est
déjà à minima on sait que il va pas y
avoir d'alignement entre le public et le
privé on sait que les régimes spéciaux
on va pas s'y attaquer donc finalement
si c'est une réforme en fait qui est une
coquille un peu vide bah oui on aura
coché la case réforme des retraites
Macron sera content il y aura pas grand
chose dedans un dernier mot pour
conclure Jean garrigue et qui se
raccorde à votre à votre livre puisque
vous avez étudié ces couples infernaux
et lisait Matignon comment il fonctionne
le duo Macron borne le petit soldat ou
soldat soldat loyal comme disait moi moi
ça me paraît très clair elle a été
choisie pour ça comme ça et ça
correspond je le répète à la sensibilité
d'Emmanuel Macron et puis à ce qui est
devenu l'équilibre institutionnel on
passe le cacher on a aujourd'hui les
présidents de la République ont
outrepassé ce qui était le périmètre
originel de la 5e République je pense
que ça pose un véritable problème
politique ça pose un problème
démocratique même mais en l'occurrence
en terme d'efficacité c'est un couple
qui qui fonctionne plutôt bien et qui
qui correspond à ce qui est devenu
aujourd'hui la 5e République en revanche
je répète moi je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir dans l'avenir à ce qu'on
revienne à quelque chose où il y aura un
vrai Premier ministre qui va gouverner
pourquoi parce que Premier ministre il
est responsable il est responsable
devant l'assemblée c'est-à-dire devant
les Français le Président si on veut pas
avoir cette accusation permanente d'un
président monarque ben il faut peut-être
lui donner moins de pouvoir et ça c'est
une vraie réflexion merci sérieux
beaucoup merci à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat et je
rappelle Jean garig le titre de votre
livre Élisée contre Matignon le couple
infernal livre publié aux éditions